right now so far the functions we've
been dealing with have already been
polynomials okay and that's because
they're the thing you're most
comfortable with differentiating
integrating they're the first ones you
encounter when it comes to calculus but
of course you can differentiate
integrate a whole bunch of other kinds
of functions not just polynomials so
let's have a go at this one right here
this is going to throw at you some
trigonometric functions and I'm going to
try and go through this question nice
and slowly and methodically but I'm
going to point out at certain points
during this solution this word solution
you're definitely going to come to a
point where you're like I'm I'm not
familiar with this it's been a while
since I've touched functions and graphs
like of this kind so what that probably
says to you is you've got some revision
to do to go back and understand those
things because they're going to kind of
become assumed knowledge for this this
is an integral calculus question there's
lots of stuff apart from integral
calculus that you need to know how to
work with so let's have a go at this
find the area bounded between y equals
sine X and like what's cos x and let me
give you a specific domain because
you're gonna see why in a second that
might be relevant but they need to say
hey justjust look within here don't just
look at it all over the entire domain
for all real values what's the first
step well we're going to start with the
first S which is sketch right now maybe
that's your first roadblock you're like
I don't know what the sketch of these
looks like thankfully you've been given
the most basic kinds of trigonometric
functions there are y cosine X Y cos cos
x and you've been given them in what we
call it like the standard domain the
domain you encounter all the time from
naught to 2pi which if you can't recall
that 360 degrees so we're going to get
one full cycle of both of these
functions okay it is important though
that it's in radians all of the results
that we know for differentiating and
integrating trigonometric functions
they'll come from radians so if you like
and there's lots of stuff you can look
at to prove that for yourself other
videos if you're curious so let's have a
go at drawing this now in this case my
accuracy is going to be quite important
so I'm going to try and do everything
with ultra straight lines you okay now
I'm going to draw this
not to 2pi and I I need to get a sense
of what these look like reasonably
accurately so I'm just going to give you
a quick crash course on how I physically
which I didn't mean to me of that how I
physically draw these things okay for
sine X I know it's roughly it's it's
this guy right it roughly looks like
that but I need to do more than just
roughly because this graph is going to
interact with another graph it's going
to give me it's going to show me where
the regions are so it needs to be good
enough that I can use that fact so from
naught to 2 pi and the important spots
to put our number 1 your endpoint that's
going to be 2 pi over here the middle of
the graph which I'm just going to
eyeball but if you have a rule obviously
you can do it more accurately it's at PI
over there
and then you're going to go up and down
from 1 to negative 1 so that's the range
of this function okay and once you've
got your one at your negative 1 if you
think back to this this general shape
again you've got this highest point and
this lowest point which occur I'm
one-quarter through the graph and then
3/4 through the graph so the relevant
values there are PI on 2 so it's going
to be a spot up there and then 3pi on 2
which is going to be here so it's gonna
be a spot there and now what I've got is
1 2 3 intercepts and then this top spot
in this bottom spot we call them beyond
the turning points right so now I'm
ready to thread the needle I'll do my
best
now I don't know how you do this but I
generally find its easiest to start at
the top go down to the bottom and then
do the same but in Reverse so you want
to make sure you go through there and
roughly through there now it's not
perfect that turning point down the
bottom looks a bit gross but it it is
good enough it goes through all the
right spots that I need so this guy is y
equals sine X now I'm going to pull out
another color one that I haven't used
yet let's go with green and now I'm
going to do y equals cos x now some of
you may recall that the the cause in a
clue sign and the coast in cosine I
should say it stands for a compliment so
it's 90 degrees or PI on 2 radians
shifted from this guy now if you can't
remember that maybe you just record the
general shape is this kind of big dipper
kind of shape right you're gonna start
at the top you end up at the bottom
right in the middle which is a pie and
then you end up back where you started
okay
and these other spots here at play on
two and three pound two they're going to
be my intercepts so I'll just label them
in Python 2 3 PI on to okay so just like
before I'm ready to try and get my
sketch here and so I'm gonna try and
thread the needle as best as I can
there we go we'll do one half and then
my I'm right-handed so the other half is
easier for me to draw if I start from
over there there we go all right like I
said not my best work but it will do the
job now what does the question say it
says find the area bounded between these
two curves in the domain 0 to 2 pi now
there's been a sneaky language in here
because the area bounded between them at
the moment is just going to be I'm going
to shade it in yellow here it's just
gonna be this part over here right but
this language in the domain naught 2 pi
actually suggests to me that there's
other lines that are being implied here
right when I say from naught to 2 pi
there's also an x equals 0 and an x
equals 2 pi line that are kind of on the
fences if you like of this boundary so
I'm just gonna put them in and then put
them in in black so I've got there's x
equals zero and there's x equals 2 pi so
now I have extra parts that I need to
worry about so I'm going to shade this
one over here in pink and I'm going to
do the same for reasons I'm going to
become clear also in pink over here on
the right hand side so you might have
remembered the previous graph we looked
at there were two regions that we had to
integrate separately here I've got three
but I wonder if you've noticed why I've
broken them up into your only two colors
and let's have a look at the other one
that's not we started with right
you've got y equals sine X which is the
blue graph and then you've got y equals
cos x which is the green graph ok so in
order to work out the area between two
curves I need to work out top takeaway
bottom this is blue takeaway green so in
order to do this area in here I'm going
to have to work out sorry that's the
wrong color I'm gonna have to work out
sign X take away cause X and I'm gonna
have to integrate from some boundary to
some other boundary to find that okay so
that's the yellow area what about the
pink area well for both of the pink
areas I should say what you've got is
the green highlighter here this is the
green part take away the blue part
that's where you start and then over on
the right-hand side you get the same
deal there's the green section on top
again take away the Blues section for so
for both of the pink areas I'm gonna
have to do cos X take away sine X and
I'm gonna have to integrate from the
appropriate values okay no my my pink
hair is they start at x equals naught
and they end x equals 2 pi that's nice
but then I've got these are these two
spots in here where the yellow integral
takes over or the pink pink integral
stops here becomes yellow then the
yellow integral it goes and then it
stops and at that point it transitions
back into being the pink integral so I
need to find out what these two spots
are just like with the questions we've
looked at before I'm gonna solve
simultaneously to find points of
intersection